aujourd'hui j'ai demandé à madame benoît
groulx écrivain et journaliste de bien
vouloir s'entretenir avec moi afin de me
poser les questions que se posent sans
doute les femmes françaises et bien
françois mitterrand je vais d'abord vous
poser une question d'ordre général on a
toujours dit que la politique c'est l
affaire des hommes et on l'a si souvent
répété que les femmes ont fini par le
croire
et j'ai l'impression que si elle se
désintéresse souvent de la politique
c'est parce qu'elles croient que leurs
problèmes personnels ne sont pas du
domaine politique
mais est ce que cette campagne
électorale ne va pas justement leur
donner une certaine maturité politique
et leur faire découvrir que tout se
tient et que non seulement le marché
commun mais l'installation de l'eau
courante dans tel village de france
dépendent finalement du choix qu'elles
vont faire le 5 décembre
l'un des objectifs essentiels
précisément de ma campagne pour la
présidence de la république est de faire
prendre conscience plus encore qu'hier
aux femmes qu'elles ont une
responsabilité civique
voyez vous elle dispose du droit de vote
depuis 1945 le général de gaulle leur a
rappelé que c'était à lui qu'elle doive
et c'est vrai de même qu organisation de
réseaux de résistance qui ont demandé au
général de gaulle de bien vouloir
prendre cette décision mais ce qui
importe aujourd'hui 20 ans après ceux de
savoir si ce droit a été suivie d'effet
et si la représentation des femmes dans
la vie professionnelle civique ou à
l'échelon national correspond
véritablement à l'évolution de
l'événement et de notre société
voilà pourquoi je pense parce que je
crois qu'en réalité les femmes n'ont pas
cette représentation qu'il faut se poser
le problème
les statistiques nous disent que environ
un tiers des femmes travaillent
est ce que dans les représentations
officielles dans tous ces organismes
il y a aussi un tiers de femmes
représentées mais non
il est difficile d'indexer la
représentation entre les femmes et les
hommes
et il ne s'agit pas de cela cependant
lorsque l'on constate de quelle manière
depuis vingt ans les femmes sont de
moins en moins représentés là où elles
ont précisément une compétence et après
tout cette compétence elle peut être
égale à celle des hommes
on a le droit de s'inquiéter il y a par
exemple à l'assemblée nationale ou au
sénat beaucoup moins deux femmes qu'il
n'y en avait naguère il n'y a pas de
femmes au conseil des ministres
écartons cet aspect politique des choses
et on a le droit de se scandaliser de
savoir par exemple qu'au conseil
d'administration de lower tf dans cette
maison où nous parlons et qui dispose
d'un énorme moyens de diffusion sur
toutes les idées sur tous les faits il
n'y a pas de femmes
songez que au conseil national les
associations familiales il n'y a que
deux femmes sur 24 membres
ce sont juste des chiffres que je jette
comme cela au gré de la discussion mais
qui nous montre bien qu'en réalité la
femme ne remplit pas le rôle auquel elle
a droit dans la vie nationale
par ailleurs c'est un fait qui est
contesté par personne
les femmes sont beaucoup plus occupé que
les hommes celle qui travaille au dehors
c'est à dire une sur trois comme nous le
disions autant plus en rentrant chez
elle tout le travail domestique à
accomplir est ce que au lieu de
raccourcir leur travail au dehors qui
pour elle une émancipation une ouverture
sur le monde
est ce qu'il ne serait pas plus urgent
de les soulager du travail domestique
parce qu'enfin le manque de logements le
manque d'eau courante manque de crèches
ou d'école c'est sur les femmes qu'il
pèse beaucoup plus que sur les hommes je
crois en effet qu'on peut se poser ce
problème au regard de deux sortes
d'obligations
il ya les femmes qui travaillent et
celles qui travaillent à l'extérieur
et puis celles qui travaillent chez elle
et puis il ya celles qui travaillent à
l'extérieur et qui ont la charge de leur
famille
de telle sorte qu on l'a dit avec dans
des termes excellent cette femme a deux
fois plus de travail que tout autre ce
sont des problèmes qu'il faut examiner
je crois séparément mais il est vrai
qu'en tout état de cause notre
organisation sociale est insuffisante
car quel que soit le sort de la femme
quelle que soit la destination et
l'obligation de son travail
de toute manière les charges de sa
famille la charge de l'enfant doit être
supporté beaucoup plus par l'état
l'étoile l'état doit venir au secours de
la femme par les organisations qui sont
bien connus mais qui ne sont pas encore
à s'étoffer
il faut assurer la garde de l'enfant il
faut assurer l'éducation première il
faut libérer la femme de la charge de la
présence constante de l'enfant et si
nous ne devons pas douter que la grande
joie de la mère de famille c'est d'avoir
ses enfants auprès d'elle il ne faut pas
tout de même en revenir au temps passé
où la seule façon de garder son enfance
était de la voir sur le dos bien
socialement le problème se pose comme
cela li sondage nous disent que beaucoup
de femmes vont voter pour le général de
gaulle quelles sont d'après vous les
raisons c'est difficile à dire d'abord
je ne connais pas toutes les raisons des
sondages ou de ceux qui font ces
sondages mais admettons que ce soit vrai
alors je pense que cela correspond aux
besoins profonds de sécurité quand les
femmes elles ont souffert plus que les
hommes de l'instabilité politique
elles craignent le devenir elles ont
besoin dans leur foyer ou dans la vie
professionnelle ou dans la vie civique
d'être sûre et du présent et de l'avenir
et peut-être que le général de gaulle
jusque là leur a donné le sentiment
d'être plus capables que d'autres de
leur apporter ce minimum de sécurité
c'est de cela d'ailleurs dont il
voudrait discuter et puis il est aussi
certain aspect assez curieux de des
réactions que j'ai pu remarquer l'autre
jour par exemple j'étais en bourgogne
j'ai parlé à une vieille dame des
milieux ruraux et nous parlions
d'élection présidentielle
elle me disait que voulez-vous maj vote
pour le général de gaulle
qu'est ce que vous voulez lui au moins
il ne fait pas de politique
eh bien je crois qu'en effet la vème
république a tenté de déshabiller les
citoyens et surtout les citoyennes des
problèmes politiques
et de leur assurer une sorte de
protection supérieure en leur évitant de
penser de réfléchir et de décider et
tout l'essentiel de ma politique à moi
c'est précisément de dire aux femmes
qu'elles sont responsables
non seulement de leur destin mais aussi
responsable du destin de notre pays
bien sûr je vais vous poser une question
sur celle de vos prises de position qui
fait le plus de sensations
il s'agit du planning familial c'est à
dire du contrôle des naissances
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de femmes
en voyant tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle se pencher
tout à coup sûr ce problème qui était à
bout jusqu ici j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup de femmes vont se croire un peu
un enjeu électoral
c'est pourquoi il serait peut-être utile
que vous nous disiez très précisément ce
que vous pensez de ce problème qui nous
touche tout est ce que vous comptez
faire si si les moyens vous en sont
donnés en effet lorsque au début de
cette campagne présidentielle j'ai dit
dans la ville de nevers qu'il convenait
de faire confiance aux femmes
quant à l'épanouissement de leurs
familles je posais le problème du
contrôle des naissances mais dans des
termes très précis j'ai dit à l'heure où
les plus hautes autorités spirituelles
ou les responsables de la vie politique
des plus grands pays du monde se pose ce
problème suivant les femmes ont-elles le
droit de ne point avoir d'enfant j'ai
préféré moi dire cela dans les termes
suivants les femmes quand les femmes on
va recommencer ça vous permet alors là
cette fois ci un que la question même
que la réponse
nous on y verse elle
là
et maintenant je voudrais
hollande
et maintenant je vais vous poser une
question sur celle de vos prises de
position qui a fait le plus sensation
il s'agit du planning familial c'est à
dire du contrôle des naissances
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de femmes
en voyant tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle se pencher à
votre suite sur ce problème
j'ai l'impression que ces femmes vont se
croire un peu un enjeu électoral
c'est pourquoi il serait peut-être utile
que vous nous disiez précisément ce que
vous pensez de ce problème qui nous
touche tout est ce que vous comptez
faire si les moyens vous en sont donnés
vous savez que les plus hautes autorités
autorité spirituelle se pose le problème
de la régulation des naissances et des
conditions modernes de l'épanouissement
de la famille vous savez que le contrôle
des naissances pour employer le terme
est connu de tous est reconnue dans les
plus grands pays du monde sans nuire à
l'expansion démographique
c'est donc un problème qui se pose est
qu'il ne faut pas nier
jusqu'ici il a été l'objet d' interdit
et de tabous et lorsque j'ai posé moi
même le problème à nevers il y a
quelques semaines je ne pensais pas que
le problème du contrôle des naissances
deviendrait à ce point un fait politique
ce n'est pas la campagne électorale
présidentielle qui oblige les candidats
a évoqué le contrôle des naissances
c'est parce que le contrôle des
naissances touche tant de femmes étant
de femmes que c'est devenu un fait
politique et qu'il appartient aux
responsables de la nation de s'en
préoccuper
en effet il faut décrire la situation
présente
va-t-on continuer de traiter les femmes
qui décident
dorian terre elle-même le sort de leurs
familles comme des criminels or il
existe une loi de 1920 qui les frappe de
prison ou une amende s'ils estiment
devoir elle même décider de leur destin
et du destin de leur foyer c'est un
problème capital parce qu'il touche à la
de l'être humain j'ai dix ans diversion
constance qu'il ne fallait pas poser ce
problème dans des termes inexactes on
dit généralement il faut donner le droit
à la femme de ne pas avoir d'enfant
jeudi il faut donner le droit à la femme
dans la voix et pour cela lui faire
confiance
lui dire lorsqu'elles se marient que
l'emploi est un certain que le salaire
est modeste que le logement est souvent
absent que toutes les charges vont
s'accumuler dans les pires conditions
qui lui appartient en confiance avec son
mari de décider pour les années à venir
de ce que sera sa famille et quand je
dis faire confiance cela veut dire que
qui pourrait croire qu'une jeune femme
n'a pas pour objectif essentiel pour ce
n'est pas nous y semant personnelle
d'avoir des enfants
encore faut-il que physiologiquement
moralement
sentimentalement l' équilibre de la
famille correspondent à la nécessité
pour la femme de ne pas être uc écrasée
de ne pas être écrasé par les
obligations devra peut-être koupéla et
attireront tout à l'heure d'ailleurs la
question parce que j'en ai dit assez
alors heureusement sont pas si nous
recommençons pas on prêtait de koupéla
tout à l'heure après douze années dit
assez
il y à certaines questions d'intérêt
général qui concerne plus
particulièrement les femmes sans doute
parce qu'elle se sent particulièrement
défavorisée l'emploi par exemple qui est
beaucoup plus difficile pour elles que
pour un garçon du même âge vous savez
que la plupart des jeunes filles de
l'agriculture ne peuvent pas accéder à
la formation professionnelle
savez vous que la part réservée aux
filles dans l'accès à l'enseignement
technique est infime par rapport aux
garçons encore les jeunes gens ont ils
eux mêmes les pires difficultés pour
disposer d'un enseignement technique qui
soit conforme aux nécessités d'économie
nationale et il est vrai que dans la
plupart des cas mais jeunes filles et
les jeunes femmes qui veulent travailler
ont beaucoup plus de peine que les
hommes à trouver un travail
en l'absence d'une qualification
professionnelle on peut imaginer qu'elle
est quelle est leur détresse et la
qualification professionnelle sont
généralement ou bien des menus travaux
de couture qui les destinent à des
salaires de misère ou bien être plantés
derrière la caisse des grands magasins
ou bien ou bien je ne sais quoi
en bref alors que gili a autant de
bachelière en france que de bacheliers
que les dispositions intellectuelles et
pratiques de la femme sont reconnus pour
appréhender les problèmes de la société
moderne
on ne leur fait pas de place vous avez
eu raison de poser ce problème capital
il ya aussi la question des salaires est
ce qu'il n'est pas aujourd'hui humiliant
et injuste de s'entendre dire couramment
par les hommes en général au pour une
femme tu gagne bien sa vie
vous savez qu'il y à une formule très
employé qui presque un slogan un travail
égal salaire égal
en réalité sur le quart des salariés
français qui perçoit moins de 55 mille
anciens francs par mois on compte 72 %
de femmes de la même manière alors qu'en
1958 le salaire féminin le salaires
masculins étaient très proches l'un de
l'autre
aujourd'hui ils sont les plus éloignés
dans l'europe occidentale et au
détriment des femmes de telle sorte
qu'on peut dire sans risque de se
on paie qu'à l'égard du salaire la femme
est considérée comme un être inférieur
alors que son rendement est le plus
souvent tu égal il se pose là aussi une
question que tout en haut responsable ne
peut que se poser et si on évite de se
poser cette question c'est quand en
réalité on refuse aux femmes leurs
droits
est ce que votre programme qui est celui
de la gauche avec des priorités
accordées au logement à l'éducation
avec aussi le refus de la course à
l'armement atomique
est-ce que ce programme ne correspond
pas à ce que devraient être les
aspirations des femmes précisément mais
précisément avant même de vous répondre
sur cette question je vous dirais que
l'emploi est difficile
le salaire est et modèles et nous
solidaires vous recommencez est ce que
vous voulez nous représenter ces dix
minutes actuellement ça nous donnera un
petit peu de temps qu'il n'en résulte et
je m'attendais à la question des règles
sur la protection sociale alors jailli
ben
là
il y a des problèmes d'intérêt général
mais qui concerne particulièrement les
femmes sans doute parce qu'elles sont
particulièrement défavorisée par exemple
l'emploi l'égalité des salaires et la
sécurité
est ce qu'il n'est pas humiliant et
injuste de s'entendre dire par exemple
aujourd'hui couramment surtout par des
hommes pour une femme qui donne bien ta
vie en effet lorsqu'on examine les
conditions de l'emploi par exemple pour
la plupart des jeunes filles jouent des
jeunes femmes
on a le droit de s'interroger est ce la
sécurité pour les jeunes filles de
l'agriculture lorsque l'on constate
aucune d'entre elles n'a en réalité
possibilité d'accéder à la formation
professionnelle est sa sécurité pour la
plupart des jeunes filles et des jeunes
femmes lorsque l'on constate qu'elles ne
peuvent accéder à la formation de
l'enseignement technique dans la mesure
même où les garçons ne sont pas
embouteiller dans cette forme
d'enseignement qui dispose de temps de m
admirable et qui est négligée par l'état
est ce la sécurité pour une jeune fille
ou pour une jeune femme lorsqu'elle
accède à un emploi elle considérait que
c'est généralement vers des menus
travaux de couture vers la station
debout tout le long de la journée
derrière une caisse de grands magasins
ou bien je ne sais quoi est ce la
sécurité du salaire lorsqu'on sait que
le quart des salariés et je le répète
sans arrêt perçoit moins de 55 mille
anciens francs par mois et que sur ses
salariés la 72 % sont des femmes
on répète comme un slogan à travail égal
salaire égal
ce n'est pas vrai en 1958 le salaire
féminin le salaire basculait était en
france très proches l'un de l'autre
en 1965 ils sont éloignés comme aucun
pays de l'europe occidentale et au
détriment de la femme dans la réalité
des choses
le salaire féminin ne correspond pas à
la qualification professionnelle et il
faut quand même pas oublier que les
femmes tout le démontre constamment il
ya autant de bachelière que de
bacheliers ont
mêmes moyens que les hommes pour
appréhender la responsabilité
professionnelle
est ce qu'il y à sécurité pour la fable
lorsqu'on sait que le gouvernement leur
promet lorsqu'elle travaillait quelle
honte à l enfant 14 semaines de congés
sans salaire et qu'on sait d'autre part
que c'est une erreur on recommence tant
pis on va leur premier 12 mois politi et
s'il le faut
il y à des questions d'intérêt général
mais qui concerne particulièrement les
femmes et ce sont justement celles où
elles sont particulièrement défavorisée
par exemple l'égalité des salaires
l'emploi et la sécurité
est ce qu'il n'est pas humiliant et
injuste de s'entendre dire couramment
encore aujourd'hui surtout par des
hommes pour une femme qui gagne bien sa
vie
on en effet le droit de s'interroger là
dessus yat-il sécurité pour la jeune
fille ou pour la jeune femme
lorsqu'on on ne la met pas en mesure
d'obtenir un emploi
savez vous que il n'y a pratiquement pas
de jeunes filles de l'agriculture qu'ils
puissent accéder à la formation
professionnelle
savez vous que l'enseignement technique
est pratiquement fermé aux filles et aux
femmes et déjà les garçons ils sont
embouteillées alors qu'arrive t-il les
femmes iront travailler pour des menus
travaux de couture des salaires
misérables ou bien ils iront se plante
debout toute la journée derrière des
caisses de grands magasins ou gars je ne
sais quoi
yat-il sécurité pour le salaire
lorsqu'on sait et je le répète sans
arrêt que le quart des salariés français
perçoit moins de 55 mille anciens francs
par mois et que là dessus il y à 72%
enfin on dit c'est presque devenu un
slogan à travail égal salaire égal et
bien en 1958 le salaire féminin était
très proche du salaire masculin
aujourd'hui et il en est absolument
éloigné au point que la france est la
dernière et les grandes nations de
l'europe occidentale sur ce point et au
détriment des femmes yat-il sécurité
pour la protection sociale la femme est
elle défendue par la société vous savez
que monsieur grandval ministre du
travail vient de promettre à celles qui
travaillent et qui ont une amphore 12
mois de congés sans salaire et quand on
sait que dans la législation actuelle
les femmes ne profite pas des quatorze
semaines qui leur sont promises parce
que ces semaines de congés sont admis
salaires et qu'elles préfèrent
concentrer
la moitié du temps pour avoir un salaire
complet parce qu'évidemment le problème
qui se pose pour elle c'est de ramener
le même somme d'argent même modique à la
maison quand on est un enfant ce n'est
pas pour partir en vacances
les charges sont plus difficiles on veut
aider tout autant que la veille le mari
et soutenir le foyer yat-il protection
sociale lorsqu'on sait que prenons
l'exemple des commerçants des artisans
combien de femmes assume cette
responsabilité professionnelle
rien ne les défends une maladie le
commerçant est l'artisan sont ruinés on
discute du problème de la retraite à 60
ans ayant la raison il faudra y venir ne
vous dis pas commencer par les femmes
usé par un travail souvent depuis le
plus jeune âge
c'est ainsi que aussi bien sur le plan
de l'emploi que du salaire et que de la
protection sociale
il n'y a pas de sécurité pour les femmes
et voilà pourquoi le candidat de la
gauche du centre gauche c'est à dire de
toutes les forces de progrès de tulare
républicain l'est républicain engagé
pour la défense de la condition humaine
doivent prendre cette responsabilité
d'apporter en 1966 l'équivalent de ce
qui fut apportée en 1936 pour la classe
ouvrière
et maintenant je voudrais bien sûr vous
poser une question sur celle de vos
prises de position qui a fait le plus de
sensations
il s'agit du planning familial ou du
contrôle des naissances
il me semble qu'en voyant tous les
candidats à votre suite s'intéressaient
tout à coup à ce problème qui était
tabou jusqu'ici il me semble que les
femmes peut être vont se sentir un peu
devenir un enjeu électoral
c'est pourquoi il serait peut-être utile
que vous nous disiez précisément ce que
vous pensez de ce problème qui nous
touche tout est ce que vous comptez
faire si les moyens vous en donner ce
n'est pas un problème électoral
c'est un fait politique on ne peut plus
ignorer maintenant que le problème du
contrôle des naissances est posée à la
nation
les plus hautes autorités spirituelles
s'en préoccupe vous le savez les plus
grands pays du monde ont déjà accepté le
contrôle des naissances
or qu'est ce qui se passe en france une
loi de 1920 traite comme des criminels
on les condamne à la prison le cas
échéant les femmes qui décide elle même
de ce que doit être l'épanouissement de
leurs familles
je n'ai pas dit comme beaucoup d'autres
disent il faut donner aux femmes le
droit de ne pas avoir d'enfants jeudi il
faut leur donner le droit d'en avoir
précisément par l'emploi par le salaire
par la protection sociale précisément
par les conditions de neige à
l'épanouissement d'un foyer pour il vit
heureux
alors il faut faire confiance aux femmes
il faut qu'elle soit maîtresse de
l'évolution de leur foyer il faut
qu'elle puisse décider en confiance avec
leurs maris de ce qui convient ou de ce
qui ne convient pas parce que imaginait
la jeune fille la jeune femme de 20 ans
et voilà que dans les pires conditions
de logement ou de travail
les enfants arrivent dix ans plus tard
les problèmes physiologiques moreau
sentimentaux dispose je dis qu'il faut
faire confiance aux femmes parce que
c'est le problème même qui concerne la
dignité de l'être humain
alors je les dis sans ambages il faudra
abroger les articles 2
loi de 1920 qui les frappe et décidé que
notre société fera place aux femmes sur
le plan de leur épanouissement complet
autant qu'aux hommes il y à là dessus un
problème de responsabilité humaine qui
nous engage et je suis sûr que celle
qu'ils m'entendent ont parfaitement
compris que ce que je dis c'est à
l'honneur de la famille les pays qui
appliquent le contrôle des naissances
n'ont pas vu diminuer leur population
mais ils ont vu au contraire la
responsabilité de la dignité de la femme
s'accroître c'est tout ce que je demande
je voudrais vous poser une dernière
question est ce que votre programme avec
les priorités accordées au logement à
l'éducation nationale avec aussi le
refus de la course à l'armement atomique
est-ce que ce programme ne correspond
pas assez précisément aux aspirations
des femmes bien jeudi en effet que je
voulais que 1966 voit la naissance d'une
véritable législation qui concerne les
femmes sur le plan du droit civil sur le
plan professionnel et sur le plan tout
simplement de leur personne mais je
voudrais reprendre mon argument et dire
il ya t'il sécurité pour les femmes
lorsque leurs enfants n'ont pas
véritablement accès dans les conditions
égales à l'éducation nationale lorsque
leur enfant risque d'effets d'être
frappé dès l'origine par la catégorie
sociale à laquelle ils appartiennent
l'éducation nationale c'est aussi une
condition du bonheur de la famille par
l'épanouissement de chacun y at il enfin
sécurité pour les femmes lorsqu'une
nation s'organisent par le surarmement
pour l'éventualité d'une guerre
impossible
le problème de la force de frappe
atomique doit être le problème majeur
pour la décision politique de toutes les
femmes de france
n'y at-il pas nécessité pour elles de
considérer que tous ceux qui établira
une société autour d'un arbitrage
international en chassant toutes les
menaces de conflits destructeurs
c'est aussi cela la sécurité profonde
elle est ravie me sens depuis l'origine
des temps ont la charge du maintien
de l'avis la continuité de la vie et de
la civilisation
voilà pourquoi j'ai estimé nécessaire ce
soir de leur poser tous un problème
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé à madame
benoîte groulx écrivain et journaliste
de bien vouloir s'entretenir avec moi
afin de me poser les problèmes qui sans
doute se posent à la plupart des femmes
de notre pays
les femmes sont beaucoup plus occupé que
les hommes c'est un fait puisque toutes
celles qui travaillent en temps plus à
un métier assuré à la maison le travail
domestique est ce qu'il ne serait pas
urgent d' alléger ce travail à la maison
étant donné que le manque de logements
le manque d'eau courante le manque de
crèches par exemple pèse finalement sur
les femmes beaucoup puisque sur les
hommes et il est vrai que toutes les
femmes travaillent à l'extérieur ou chez
l insecte qui travaillent à l'extérieur
et qui ont une famille que de problèmes
et les certains également que l'état est
mal équipé pour venir au secours de ces
femmes comme il le doit
le manque de garderie de crèches
le jardin d'enfants et dès l'entrée à la
maternelle on le sait bien l'année 1965
n'a fait qu'aggraver le problème
on ne reçoit pas tous les enfants alors
faudra-t-il que comme dans les temps
ancestraux
le rôle de la femme ce soin de porter
son enfant sur son dos je pense aussi
aux problèmes d'équipements collectifs
où l'état ne remplit pas son devoir
quand on songe qu une femme des milieux
ruraux sur deux n'a pas l'eau à la
maison et la question je bouge plus
qu'on ne le croit dans l'ensemble de
l'agglomération parisienne
voilà pourquoi je pense qu'en effet
l'état a des devoirs à remplir et qu'il
m'importe d'y répondre
un nazi
le faire
les femmes sont plus occupés que les
hommes c'est un fait
toutes celles qui travaillent ou dehors
on entend plus un travail domestique a
assuré à la maison est ce qu'il ne
serait pas primordial de soulager ce
travail domestique et oui en réalité
toutes les femmes travaillent que ce
soit à l'extérieur ou que ce soit chez
elle et celles qui sont à l'extérieur
ont le plus souvent une famille c'est
pourquoi on a le droit de s'étonner
devant l'absence d'équipement de l'état
pour venir au secours de ces femmes
faudrait-il en revenir aux origines
ancestrales et que la femme et la charge
de son enfant le portant sur le dos il
faut des crèches il faut des garderies
faut des jardins d'enfants davantage
encore il faut songer qu'à la maternelle
ont refusé enfants toujours faute
d'équipement
songeons et c'est un problème
d'équipement collectif capital qu'une
femme sur deux des milieux ruraux n'a
pas l'eau à la maison et que la question
se pose dans d'autres domaines puisque
l'agglomération parisienne elle même
manque de cet équipement minimum oui
vous avez raison de le dire l'état
manque à son devoir
et c'est pourquoi il faut y remédier